winter storm systems will impact
millions of people from Texas to Maine
over the next few days San Antonio Texas
saw rare snowfall overnight more than
two inches fell for the first time in
more than 30 years the system is making
its way through the south and up the
Northeast winter weather alerts are in
effect from the Mexican border to the
Canadian border nearly 18 inches of lake
effect snow fell in parts of New York
Pennsylvania and Michigan and at least
one person in Michigan died in the storm
Don Dahler is in Hamburg New York where
the snow is already piling up Don good
morning winter is here it is here from
fire to ice this morning right it's been
snowing steadily here in Hamburg
overnight some of this region has been
reporting 15 inches but I want to show
you I think right around here we have
about a foot that has accumulated now
people are used to winter blast here in
the Buffalo area but when it comes all
at once it can be dangerous and the
concern this morning is obviously the
commute there whiteout conditions in
some parts of the region and very slick
streets the plows and the police have
been out all night trying to make sure
people get to where they need to go
safely but in Michigan the conditions
caused a 20-car pileup yesterday we saw
a lot of cars struggling slipping and
sliding trying to get up hills but we
also witnessed something really unusual
a four-wheel drive pickup truck pulling
a tree my tractor trailer rig off of an
icy patch that's quite a commercial for
that car company it's been relatively
warm here until recently so some people
have had a hard time adjusting to the
new reality and we saw some folks who
are actually shoveling in shorts and
shirtless Nora oh my goodness alright
Don thank you so much